you know it's funny people say that he
won't pardon snowden or assange
because he's called them both you know
treasonous traitors spies and all stuff
but but there was a funny tweet where
someone uh i think glenn greenwald
tweeted about it
and then someone said why would trump
pardon them he's repeatedly insulted
them and called them you know names
and then glenn greenwald said something
the effect of maybe it's because
he these people are have targeted the
deep state
intelligence agencies which attacked and
and you know harassed trump for years
and now he will enjoy some comeuppance
or some karma for these people
yeah i mean he has the power to do it
but we also have to understand that it's
because of the trump administration why
julian assange is where he is
right now it's because of his direct
actions and his administration
that assange is in such a terrible place
but you know snowden just tweeted out
don't pardon me please pardon assange
save his
life his life is on the line you know
why trump is doing it
and why trump did what obama wouldn't
why i
think trump wants to know who wikileaks
sources are
that was that was the part of the deal
part of the bargain that allegedly
happened between the trump
administration and assange that was
public
uh that assange yeah i mean wasn't that
public i don't know that
i remember reading articles about that
in here there you go about that specific
story that trump wanted to know who the
source was for the dnc leaks and if
assange gave it to him
assange would be let go if he didn't he
would feel the full
brunt of the us empire and he did and
julian assange
will not sacrifice his legacy and his
his organization
and so you got to give him up to you've
got to give it up to him i mean that's
courageous
he's sitting in solitary yeah he gave up
his life because he wouldn't give up his
source
and that's more integrity than than an
iota of what the mainstream yeah
they'll make a movie they'll make like
movies but you know what you know the
you know the scary thing about it is the
difficult question
if we did get the source for the dnc
leaks
officially on record from assange i
think
it would have been a game changer that
would have reshaped the culture war and
politics in this country especially
pertaining to russia gate and where we
are today with ukraine gate everything
happened the impeachment
it would have i i believe
are you referring to seth rich no okay
so that that's
that's i i don't i don't know what where
that all is but i do know
that you had someone from wikileaks say
that they were handed the drive right
if maybe it was russia maybe it wasn't
the point is it would have either
confirmed
or didn't or or rejected that conclusion
in which case we would have known
definitively
let's say it was russia if we got that
answer out of assange then we could have
been like
whoa trump did get information
wikileaks was used as a as an useful
idiot
so that they could undermine blah blah
blah or it turns out the media and
everything was wrong
and it undermines the entire russia gate
but at the same time he's still
accommodating to the lunatics in the
mainstream media that are literally
regurgitating and making crazy theories
up
about russian uh pete i was nuts
why would you even try to appease him
and if you try to appease him in
exchange for julian assange's life i
mean that's messed up that's absolutely
horrible
and i agree this is a complex picture
you can't just paint donald trump
black or white good or bad it's far more
complex than that because
he did talk about bringing the troops
back he actually brought back 700 u.s
troops from somalia no no they're
getting they're getting moved around
well they're getting whatever out of
there
and most of americans didn't even know
that the united states had troops
positions
increasing the west wars dude yeah
there's an africom whole entire u.s
military unit
inside of the whole african continent
raging war right now you know arming
different factions and i you know i've
been there i've been on the front lines
in somalia and the picture that's
happening there is not a good one and it
doesn't do any favors to the united
states so
i i mean when it comes to assange i mean
look at the work he did look at the
information he
he released especially with bradley
manning chelsea man excuse me
especially with everything we were we
actually got to find out about the u.s
military-industrial complex that we
would never know as
as many on the right say the reason why
they're adamant about trump pardoning
assange and snowden is that they exposed
the deep state
yes these intelligence man think about
how crazy it is
that for the longest time if you came
out and said
they're they're waging a secret war in
somalia they beg ooh
these crazy guys thinks the cia is
coming to get them they call you a
conspiracy theorist crackpot
and then trump comes along and all of a
sudden not just trump but with assange
people like snowden
the veil starts to get removed and it
turns out could you imagine if the
american people actually knew
how many secret wars we were engaged in
what they would do
they'd probably revolt yeah people don't
realize this mo's and
and and you know what makes it makes it
work the mainstream media these large
media organizations are complicit
they cover it up because i'll tell you
this
i was in a i was at a resort in turkey
in um what's uh what's the eastern city
in turkey where they do this this is
it's like the russian resort i can't
remember the name
tons of rich people i was brought there
by this by the executives at vice
top level people top men top men top men
they bring me to this resort antalya
i think that's what it's called so i'm
hanging out with with the
the global elites man i'm talk we're
talking people who run telecoms
like ceos etc they're having this
meeting where they're talking about
north korea
because vice had gone into north korea
multiple times
and so you get all these rich people
sitting around and and you get shane
smith
who mentions that the state department
actually contacted
vice following the uh the north korean
documentary stuff they did
i actually worked on one of the north
korea documentaries for vice called
north korean
motorcycle diaries i went to new zealand
for that because they had the footage
it was the crew that the people they
rode motorcycles through north korea
the state department wanted to talk to
vice about it so when you actually have
people in the u.s government and i'm not
saying it's a conspiracy it's not they
go there and say this is what you report
or else
it's look look we've got serious
security concerns
we just want to make sure that what your
report doesn't get anybody killed you
don't want
us to come out and say you got someone
killed you no no no no no no so we're
going to tell you
okay just to be sure and then you'll get
like the new york times the wall street
journal the washington post i don't care
what their leaning is
they're going to have a story and it's
going to be like we uncovered something
and then they're going to get a phone
call saying that will undermine national
security or they're going to
national security leverage story's gone
then assange
drops it right on the internet and we
can all watch it
the system that you're describing gets
overused and abused
many times as even regular stories that
don't have any implications don't put
anyone's life
on the line are actually censored
because they make the united states look
bad that has happened a lot and we have
found out because of chelsea manning's
uh drop that that one of the major
allegations that the mainstream media
was was labeling against her was that
she put american soldiers at lives
at the court perspective at risk yeah
yeah yeah that that
people were going to die because of
these leaks i was
at the court proceedings where chelsea
manning was
at at what was it uh what's the specific
military court called
leavenworth oh i don't know um there was
a specific military procedure
where she was being tried i was there
and it came out that there was
no one put at risk because of these
leaks that were
that were put out there but she still
was oddly punished by the obama
administration
you've got a plan and then some dude
comes out and tells everyone what your
plan is
you're going to be really really angry
and annoyed and that's and that's it and
the issue with the with assange manning
was snowden michael flynn
with isis right yeah is that if if if
we need to make an example of you
michael flynn is a really good example
because i didn't
i didn't realize that until you brought
it up that michael flynn basically
what did he snitched out closed how
barack obama was responsible for the
rise of isis in the middle east
knowingly he knew there was leaked
documents that came out that showed
exactly what was going to happen it did
radical fundamentalists were going to
receive the money the arms the
intelligence the hardware
the trucks that were sent down there
this is why isis was
riding around with jim bob's
construction trucks from the united
states
and everyone was like wait why did they
have there's a phone number phone number
on it from michigan yes
they were running around with humvees us
military humvees that they knew they
were going to get in iraq and there's
even
leaked documents coming out how the u.s
military command
knew that they were going to get a
control of all this this is all there
from the u.s military and they let it
and this is why they thought or they
they claimed that flynn was compromised
by russia
because syria was allies with russia and
all the pieces come together
exactly but he came out and read it on
them and that they got they got to make
an example
because they don't want anybody else to
do it so listen you could
you could commit a major felony right
and they'll and they'll say okay yeah
sure we're gonna we're gonna lock you up
and go through the system
but you slight the machine and they are
going to
gut and they're going to eviscerate you
and leave you hanging to dry
as the public watches because now you
know we're hearing a judge
just said in the part in in in the
pardon of michael flynn
that perhaps sullivan could order that
the pardon is too broad
and try to nullify it how psychotic
is this that is a supreme power granted
to the president
okay a lot of people have complaints
about the pardon power
it exists for a reason i actually read a
great essay on i can't remember exactly
what the breakdown was
but they say there's a very serious and
important reason why the president has
the ability to just pardon people when
it comes to federal crimes
but if the president does so be it
that's at least the rules for now if you
don't like the rules you change the
rules later with legislation the fact
that they're saying
that sullivan who was blocking the fact
that the doj was trying to let flynn go
like
doj says we're going to drop this we
don't want to do it anymore and then you
get this judge saying no
no you can't do that then trump says i
unequivocally pardoned
now there's one judge going i don't know
that's a little broad sullivan could say
no to that
oh we can't say was not the president
the president so
it will i i don't think anything's come
of it but man are these people
nuts yeah so i'll tell you this the
reason why it is absolutely
important in my opinion that
we get resolution on all of what's going
on with the election irregularity
is because we are we you know often say
we're sitting on a powder keg
the fuse is coming and we're staring at
it that powder powder keg's about to go
january 6 is around the corner january
20th around the corner and you got 74
million people saying
what is going on with this election i
don't trust it more than that probably
you got 30
of democrats according to a couple
different polls that think votes were
stolen
so you've got people charged up and
ready
and angry people are going to snap as we
were locked down
denied sports and are now being put
back into lockdown having all of our
livelihoods destroyed in front of us i
mean this is an absolute
recipe for disaster so many people are
discontent so many people are angry a
lot of them are just
breaking stuff because they have nothing
else to do if you go to major democratic
cities
you could protest you could riot yup you
could work nope you could go check that
you can't go to church you can't have
sporting events you can't have you can't
go to the clubs
you can't go to the restaurants you
can't do anything except riot it's
simple
when uh when ryan long was here he's a
comedian super funny guy he's ryan long
comedy it's really really great stuff
you probably love it
he was saying that you know he's in new
york they couldn't go outside or do
anything
the black lives matter protest started
and he was like i want to go outside
and that was it they got those massive
numbers you see that video in california
of all the people in the street as a
drone flies over
it's because people were desperate let
me out into the sun please
any excuse i'll say anything and it
worked
yep i will say anything and a lot of
people are angry at the police for
enforcing
a lot of these decrees i call it yeah a
lot of people were justifiably pissed
off because
their sheriff their local police officer
locked them in
and used the full might of the police
state against them because they wanted
to live
oath breakers yes and that's why people
were legitimately angry at the police
and and they're going to be angry again
because the officers are still
continuing to listen to those orders
so this is why one of the reasons why i
voted for trump
um clearly i'm not the biggest trump
supporter in the world but i think he's
infinitely better than joe biden
i think he's done good on foreign policy
we had a big argument you know he's
conscious he could talk
well yeah that's for sure joe biden came
what did he say he was like you know if
we get an argument with kamala you know
like i said
obama i'll just say i contracted a
disease and then resigned
what he would have done as the vice
president he was saying when out he said
he said that in in a dispute with kamala
just like he said with obama
so what he said was he will he would
have done it with obama and he'll do it
i think he said he would have done obama
and kamala he wants kamala to do that
with him
no he said he would expect her to back
off no he would say
he said what i would say to her like i
said i don't know he would said he would
resign if his vice president
i could pull up the clip yeah literally
sounded like it but i think what he
meant was as vp
no no no no we're not playing we're not
playing that game where we're gonna
translate for joe biden
that's what the dude what idiot what
would you say if my vp didn't just
fight joe biden illness and resign from
the president
the controversy i i disagree
no i think he was making an allegory
from what he would have done as vp to
what his vp would do we could look up
the exact quote
we should look it up but it should also
be surprising to a lot of people that
joe biden had this biden says he would
resign if a moral dispute with harris
arose
in this quote from the street certified
by news guard
no you are well i disagree like i told
barack
if i reach something where there's a
fundamental disagreement we have based
on moral principle i'll develop some
disease and say i have to resign
he said that when he said what he would
tell barack right
like i told barack he was asked how he
would respond to kamala harris and he
said like i told barack
what he said was he would have done with
obama and he'll do it
like he told barack the vice president
would do it with obama and the vice
president would do it literally making
that up that was my interpretation it
doesn't matter you're making that up
he was asked what do you how do you
resolve a dispute with harris
and he said you know if you know i i i i
i he said that a million times
if i'm in a dispute with harris like i
told barack i'll say i'll develop a
disease until after resign
he told c anderson cooper that he would
do the same thing he would have known
with obama if harrison heaven is i'm not
going to
waste time arguing this with you i don't
understand how you're arguing it's a
quote
another thing he said is
he also announced today that there's
going to be a hundred days of
mass a hundred days of course listen
luke luke
he was in the basement he didn't know
what he didn't realize we were already
wearing masks
i know that's the thing according to the
cdc data most of americans already wear
masks
they haven't stopped wearing masks and
this was even confirmed by the new york
times
so so him saying that everything's going
to go back to normal everything's going
to be fine if people just wear a mask
for the next hundred
hundred days is again just another
delusional crazy thing
leave joe alone man he was in the
basement okay he didn't know what was
going on does he mean like in houses
is that what is a hundred percent
between bites in your own home like
california said
california's like you gotta wear a mask
in your own home and and you lift your
mask up take bites and put the mask back
on you know it was tweeted by the
official governor of california twitter
account
as uh gavin newsom was literally at that
restaurant
meeting with the california board of
health thousands of
dollars uh spending thousands of dollars
at this restaurant joe biden said he
would resign i'm starting to think
remember what he probably will i mean
kamala literally was saying
you know this is going to be the great
president can we show this again
yeah i'm not i want to listen to it can
you listen to it this is not what i'm
there's not be let's play let's see if
can we play this
but all kidding aside the first lady to
be told me she holds them for you
yes she does but not with she's because
she's she and
become friends but all kidding aside
it's
it's a matter of the thing we are
simpatico
on our philosophy of government and
simpatico
on how we want to attach approach these
issues that we're facing
and so i don't have and when we disagree
it'll be just like
so far it's been just like when barack
and i did it's in private she'll say i
think we should do a b c
or d and i'll say i don't i like a don't
like b and c
and let's go okay but and i like i told
barack
if if if i reach something where there's
a fundamental disagreement we have based
on
a moral principle i'll uh i'll i'll i'll
i'll develop some disease and say i have
to resign
um we don't have that i'm we haven't and
we discussed at length
our views on foreign policy on domestic
policy
he he was talking about what he would do
not what she and what he would expect
her to do i think
he would say that his ex expectation is
that if the vice president has a deep
philosophical disagreement with him that
why they would resolve come on man dude
he didn't say the words vice president
well he didn't say
i would resign this presidency i mean he
wasn't that specific
like i told barack if i reach something
where there's a fundamentals agreement
where i have based on a moral principle
i'll develop a disease and say i have to
resign yeah as the vice president like
that's what he would have told you
you're making that voice
he's just literally making stuff up well
he wasn't the president with barack what
does that have to do with anything
he would expect the vice president to
resign why is the president negotiating
with the vice president on what they
should or shouldn't be they're not first
place they're not he just said he was
he's going to have a private
conversation about and then if it come
to disagreement like he said with barack
he'll resign
right you're trying to defend the guy
when he didn't say dude i have no
defense of that idiot
first of all i feel like what they do
with franklin delano roosevelt hiding
his polio
for years makes me think that they're
going to hide this guy's illness as long
as that's what they're doing with the
foot man
he took his booty off when he went on
the interview and then was like wait
wait
wait
wait
he's just old and losing his mind i
don't think he's an idiot he's just
falling apart
he's the corporate establishment
representative that will say anything
that they give them to read that's what
he's been throughout his entire have you
seen those big teleprompters where the
letters are really big
yes i feel sorry for the man more than i
do disdain
listen listen listen ian do you know
that nancy pelosi
put forth the 25th amendment provision
creating a council
to to determine whether or not because
it's a the 25th amendment says
i think it's the 25th right is that what
it was the one it says
that congress has the right to appoint a
you know a group
or whatever or so what nancy pelosi was
saying is
we'll have a panel that will evaluate
the mental fitness of the president and
everyone's like you're doing this to get
rid of trump she's no it's not for trump
it's for our future president everyone's
like
it's for biden we know it's for biden
like
listen everybody was questioning why joe
biden he's 78 he's the oldest president
ever there's no way he can run for a
second term and now we have a video
coming out where he says if i get no
dispute
i'll say i have some disease and resign
and everyone's like we know and in there
they're like yeah yeah she's sick and
they're right now
he's back on track he's back out trying
it's like she's like got this look like
she's waiting for him to go
she's smiling thinking like soon soon
i will be i tweeted this is really funny
i tweeted um when that thing
story was breaking it would kind of suck
if the first female president was due to
process and not
vote i i stand by that opinion i think
it's true
i think if we want to have a female
president it was it's because the
american people said this is the right
person for the job
and not because somebody dies or is
now infirm and needs to be removed or
but but but all these social justice
leftists started
like rapping all over me and attacking
me i'm like you think it's better that
we get a met like by mandate
the first meal president like that
that's bad historical precedent and no
one supported her in the primary
no one she got no vote no no elect no no
no she is no
an evil prosecutor if you look at her
police record i mean
oh my goodness it is deplorable it is
insane to see
how many innocent people had their lives
ruined
because of kamala harris whether she
laughs whether it was smoking marijuana
whether it was crimes that they didn't
commit that she knew
they didn't commit she still put them in
jail threatening
impoverished single mothers with prison
time because their true sons were
missing
yes they didn't go to school because if
their you know children didn't show up
to school
parents would literally face legal
repercussions that they had to
fight in court that led to devastating
effects
i'm sorry can you can we just think
about this for a second so when i was a
kid
we had kerf we have curfew in chicago if
you're under the age of 17 cops can
literally just take you and bring you to
your home and then someone has to sign
for you
i thought that was always crazy that
they have something like that but think
about it this way truancy laws are
literally saying
your children must be institutionalized
as we see
otherwise you go to prison when did we
cross
that line that the state can by mandate
institutionalize your children
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you